buenas noches
muchas gracias por estar aquí es un
honor estar en el colegio nuevamente
después de tantos años les digo que
jamás me pare aquí me podía morir del
susto entonces es irónico estar hoy en
día aquí parado en mi colegio frente a
mis hijos uno se gradúa este año la otra
dentro de poquito
de que les quiero hablar de algo que
todos tenemos de la ontología vamos a
ver qué tan bueno es eso qué es lo que
hacemos todos los días realmente soy un
tipo afortunado tengo dos maestros en la
vida mi padre que está acá con quien
trabajo es mi partner mi maestro en la
vida personal y profesional y le ha
aprendido muchísimas cosas sobre todo la
perseverancia y ese valor y ese deseo de
hacer las cosas bien toda su vida muchas
gracias papá y otro gran maestro el
doctor julián osorio en boston cuando
tuve la oportunidad de estudiar y ver la
vida de una forma diferente él me
despertó esa pasión por la
odontología digital estuve en el momento
oportuno en el lugar adecuada julián fue
el creador de la odontología digital o
el virtual batman design gael el diseño
virtual de los abad mens y eso experto
en mí una idea loca de hacer cosas
fantásticas pero me tomo 24 años darme
cuenta que era lo que realmente me
importaba en la odontología y fue
gracias al amor de la natura a la
naturaleza esas salidas a tratar esas
montadas en bicicleta cada vez salía y
decía que estas cosas tan hermosas y ha
estado aquí al pie de mi casa yo me
acuesto y lo primero que veo en mi casa
son los farallones eso es aquí el
tránsito lo vemos todos los días pico de
loro me voy a mi consultorio y volteó a
mirar pico de loro y nunca había subido
en todo el tiempo que son el colegio
jamás había subido allá créanme que las
veces que he subido que han sido ya
pues las cosas de una manera
espectacular entonces gracias en la
apreciación de la naturaleza me di
cuenta que era lo que hacíamos lo puede
llevar por un tour de lo menos feo de la
ontología fue bastante difícil primera
vez que hablo a un público no
odontológico vamos a ver cómo nos va
qué pasa con esto tengo la fortuna de
poder ver en mi consultorio todo tipo de
pacientes al estar con mi padre veo este
tipo de restauraciones en oro y durante
miles de años mi padre lleva 55 años de
ejercicio profesional y sigue ejerciendo
la ontología esto sí no está mal no
debería cambiarse el hecho que podamos
hacer ese tipo de restauraciones solo
tiene una razón que haya una caries
debajo porque el hecho de que podamos
hacer con materiales espectaculares y
lograr mimetizar lo que en la naturaleza
no significa que estemos cambiando no
importa en manos de quien esté no
importa cuan hábil sea el operador cada
vez que trabajamos tocamos un poquito
más de diente
pasábamos entonces a estos casos una
mujer que necesita rehabilitarse tiene
esas prótesis de quitarse y ponerse que
son muy incómodas la sonrisa no era muy
agradable al lado derecho del mío
izquierdo de ustedes verán como inició y
cómo terminar la paciente no solamente
estamos restaurando los dientes sino la
encía y no solamente la encía sino la
autoestima de esa paciente no es fácil
arrancarle sonrisas a un paciente cuando
lo que tiene en su boca con lo que tiene
que comunicarse alimentarse presentarse
no es lo que ellos quisieran y el hecho
de que podamos hacer ese tipo de
restauraciones y que parecieran
naturales porque podríamos hacer eso
totalmente simétrico pero le ponemos un
poquitico de naturaleza que se vea la
encía como si fueren cia que se fueran
los dientes apiñados o torcidos
entonces cada vez encontramos casos y
casos diferentes
tenemos que saber hasta dónde van las
limitaciones de lo que hacemos si
encontramos ese diente central con una
raíz como oscura hay muchos
procedimientos para aclararlo pero vale
la pena hacerlo en este paciente
específicamente realmente no es un labio
largo no importa cuantos chistes cuántas
cosas le digamos no se va a notar
entonces no vale la pena sobre tratar a
estos pacientes muchas veces y este
paciente se pueden acercar a él y los
dientes parecen naturales
o estos otros y de pronto sería muy
evidente decir ah claro ya me la pille
está arriba fallaste jaramillo vi cuál
eran los dientes no estaba hablando de
los de abajo los de arriba eran
evidentemente falsos pero los de abajo
se asemejan a la nota a lo natural
esa es la búsqueda por lo que hacemos se
llama biomimetismo queremos que todo lo
que hacemos en la autoría parezca
natural que pase desapercibido no
importa cuán cerca estemos o casos estos
son casos de accidentes la mayoría o de
mal praxis todo tipo de causas son
pacientes ya mayores este podría ser un
accidente con un niño que salta y te
golpea el diente un batazo o una caída
lo que fuera pero no solamente estamos
restaurando el diente sino la forma la
textura pero detrás de eso le estamos
devolviendo la autoestima al paciente
y está bien siempre y cuando lo que
hagamos sea similar a lo que allí
hacemos dientes bonitos como el anterior
o asiento hacemos dientes feos como éste
hay que aprender a hacer dientes feos
porque la idea es que parezca
desapercibido que gano yo con decirle
ven y te pongo esos dientes blancos
espectaculares como una pianola es
horroroso eso no tiene razón de ser en
la naturaleza esto es natural esto es lo
que la naturaleza nos muestra nos vamos
envejeciendo y ya no somos lo mismo
lamentablemente este frenesí estético
está cambiando los paradigmas de la
ontología y nos estamos desviando de lo
que realmente importante estamos
perdiendo la esencia de lo que nos
formamos de ese ese juramento que
hicimos de hacer las cosas bien con
ética con profesionalismo entonces este
deseo también y no ser capaces de
decirle hombre pues no necesitas eso hay
cosas mejores entonces empezamos a ver
sus diseños de sonrisa
no importa con que lo hagamos el
envejecimiento viene con retracción de
la encía y ese borde citó amarillo
empieza a aparecer es cuestión de tiempo
y si es en resina se le vio en cayendo y
los porte citó se le veía antes picando
y estaba muy aburrida pero nadie le
contó que había detrás de él y podemos
hacer cosas mejores en materiales
mejores pero no se trata de eso porque
nadie lo contó este paciente que para
haberse colocado de eso
tiramos una gran cantidad de esmalte a
la basura y ese nunca lo volveremos a
recuperar y no importa lo hábiles que
seamos y que realmente lo que hagamos
parezcan dientes y que les volvamos a
esa hermosa sonrisa esa paciente que
parezca realmente natural porque
posiblemente si esa paciente ahora ha
tenido la posibilidad de no hacerse el
tratamiento y tener sus dientes les
hubieran sido muchísimo mejor
a esa le fue bien qué tal este parece
unas teclas de piano horroroso y lo
vemos día a día de pronto tengo la
jubilación ya anticipada y asegurada
esto lo vemos en una cantidad abrumador
y está creciendo de forma triste es
lamentable ver esto y este pobre
paciente no es una cuestión de estética
eso empieza a fracasar se filtran
bacterias la adaptación de esas
restauraciones son horrorosas y logramos
quitarle la totalidad de las
restauraciones pero algo pasó en la
sonrisa
parece nuevo vemos dos puntos a los
lados en los colmillos y huevos se
perdieron los centrales y los laterales
entonces en vez de hacerle 24 carillas
de resina que le hicieron hicimos 4 y no
la necesitaba conocí a este paciente
antes de y le había pedido todas las
formas no te hagas eso no necesitas nada
es perfecto
pero después de un intento de un diseño
de sonrisa quince días después llega y
en esto terminamos si ven la gran
mayoría de los dientes se pueden
recuperar y la encía se fue recuperando
es la belleza de lo natural se recupera
rápidamente si somos cuidadosos cómo lo
hacemos
y siempre y cuando sea porque han hecho
restauraciones o porque era necesario
hacerlo porque tuvo un accidente porque
no todos los medios para cuidarse lo que
dicen cuánto cuesta un cepillo de
dientes de una crema dental
cuando hacemos algo porque el paciente
lo requiere porque había algo congénito
o porque con un accidente ahí está bien
y extiende a su odontólogo que haga algo
que pase total y absolutamente
desapercibido porque tenemos toda la
tecnología y toda la habilidad es
cuestión de encontrar el grupo adecuada
esta paciente miren la sonrisa rate que
es una de mis técnicas o era una
ministra es fabulosa no se reía le
faltaban es el lateral citó amarillo no
le permitía sonreír y era una
malformación congénita pero un diente
que salen así como un fusil entonces es
fácil hacerlo y eso está bien había una
malformación eso ha dañado su autoestima
no la permitía sonreír y ser feliz por
ese pequeño problema pero qué tal es
este es una colega rehabilitadora es la
segunda vez que la rehabilitar la
primera vez le hice unas láminas de
porcelana y duraron mucho tiempo al cabo
de los años vino
unas semanas después de su segunda
rehabilitación me dice cambiarme esto
que me quedó muy mal y terminamos en
este y uno dice como bonito no pero no
se trata de eso
miren el desgaste que hay detrás ya no
eran láminas y todo lo que tumbamos de
ese diente y la hipersensibilidad y si
le contamos el paciente ya no pueden
morder tanto uno no ese cimiento está
como débil ya no es lo mismo que tu
diente natural que podrías morder no es
todo pero cositas más fuertes entonces o
cuidado con lo que prometemos o si les
contamos algo díganos doctor cuéntenos
lo todo lo bueno y lo mal
nos hablan del metal y nos dicen metal
se puede o no se puede doctor claro que
se puede pero si yo te cuento cuáles son
las limitaciones de la parte metálica el
metal tiene unas voluntades fantásticas
puedo esconder la parte estética sin
problema en un paciente totalmente
dentro se llama hueco si hablo términos
ontológicos mails es muy y le colocamos
unos tornillos para soportar eso y
atornillaron en boca ese paciente puede
comer nada mayor que una manzana
fantástico puede ser cuestión de precio
lo que lo hagamos allí pero tenemos que
contarle qué limitaciones son materiales
menos biocompatibles o sea que su
organismo no lo acepta tan bien como los
nuevos materiales
entonces si les contamos cuáles son las
diferencias vamos empezando a ver que
realmente estéticamente esto no tiene
mucha diferencia si vemos el color de su
piel el color de su encía y todo eso el
otro un tipo más trigueño es un tipo más
claro pero aquí estamos buscando
materiales más avanzados más avanzados
en biotecnología en la forma como el
organismo responde a ellos más similar a
lo que hay en la naturaleza a la encía
al hueso a los dientes
y en este caso buscábamos era cambiar
nuestras primeras prótesis que por
limitaciones tecnológicas porque no
habíamos llegado a lo que tenemos hoy en
día las hacíamos en oro y en acrílico
como la vena arriba y esto es un nicho
de bacterias la cosa más espectacular y
luego otro es que podíamos cambiarlo a
un material mejor más biocompatible y si
hoy en día me ofrecen la de arriba por
precios les diría no no es el precio las
de arriba se deterioran más rápidamente
me pueden producir una enfermedad
periodontal que haga que no sólo uno
sino la totalidad de lo que tengo me
pueda fracasar entonces realmente no es
cuestión de precio es cuestión de que
nosotros le podamos indicar a nuestros
pacientes que la de abajo si aporta un
poco más de dinero le va a durar
muchísimos más años va a ser más fácil
de limpiar para él va a requerir menos
idas al odontólogo entonces tenemos que
poner en una balanza todos los pros y
los contras y dejarle después de
explicarle todo lo bueno y lo malo que
es lo que hay
y si utilizamos hoy en día toda esta
información y decir no es que yo te
laiseka thq a mí eso fue en un robot
como efectivamente fue eso no importa
eso no lo importante y finalmente ese
paciente no va a andar con un letrero
mis dientes me los hizo una computadora
me lo hizo una fresadora nada uno quiere
estar contento como agradable poder
hablar con una persona acercarse besar a
la novia al marido a lo que sea y que
sientan que lo que hay o que ni siquiera
se den cuenta que eso está allí
y pasamos a las cosas más pequeñitas
desde la forma como cimentamos un
pequeño tornillo un diente y empieza una
pequeña inflamación por desconocimiento
por inhabilidad y un pequeño fragmento
de cemento como se ve abajo en el
tornillo me genera una gran inflamación
créanme que ésta es mínima sino que no
quería asustarlos con lo que vemos a
diario y logramos hacer algo atornillado
mucho más efectivo mucho más pulido
mucho menos invasivo para el tejido el
tejido responde inmediatamente como lo
ven a la izquierda
entonces qué está pasando con nosotros
tenemos todo el soporte tecnológico toda
la capacidad para hacerlo y es
fantástico
esta es una mujer de 80 años totalmente
mueca arriba abajo hacemos la impresión
3d de la mandíbula vemos en una
tomografía dónde está el nervio hacemos
unas guías para hacer la cirugía guiada
colocamos implantes y el mismo día le
estamos atornillando una prótesis sale
con su prótesis tim y creemos que eso en
un día no detrás de eso hay un estudio
grande tenemos que ver las tomografías
la forma tridimensional del hueso
tenemos que ver esas restauraciones
previas para colocarlo a 1.2 milímetros
del nervio tenemos que hacer todo el
diseño de estas estructuras que van en
boca colocarlas y probarlas en boca y
ver cómo quedan ser resultados no es tan
rápido simplemente la tecnología nos
ayuda a ser mejores odontólogos a gastar
menos tiempo en boca del paciente para
que una vez lleguemos allá nos diga
doctor que marchara pero todo lo que
llevamos atrás estudiando para poder
efectuar y hacer eso efectivamente
rápido
y hacerlo parecer sencillo es lo que es
realmente importante
a los 80 años yo diría que está bien
hacer es porque de pronto no tuvo la
posibilidad de que alguien le explicará
cómo podía prevenir lo que le estaba
pasando o la forma como le fueron
sacando los dientes para que venga para
que no sufra en la vida yo le saco es me
acuerdo en el rural cuando estaba en el
rural hito con estamos en samacá boyacá
y me trae una hijita lindísimo una
bonita y la hija el panadero en un tipo
importante entre el cura el panadero
eran como los dueños del pueblo verdad y
me dice la abuelita sacarle los dientes
para que no sufra suele tener dientes
horrible oiga rías de eso ahora sí que
me acuerdo de su que tristeza
pero la logré convencer no sé si el otro
antólogos y dijo no en casa que es
porque de verdad va a sufrir con un
[ __ ]
entonces cuando empezamos todos estos 20
años en mi deseo de crecer de ser un
grano con todo luego de hablar en
públicos y en conferencias
internacionales y mostrar de lo que era
capaz y de la tecnología que podía hacer
me estaba olvidando de la esencia y veía
más el diente que yo había hecho y me
olvidaba el vecino que era el diente con
el que veníamos la encía con la que
veníamos el hueso con el que habíamos
nacido ese no lo logramos reemplazar
nada eso es mejor que lo que tenemos en
la boca entonces cuando empezamos a ver
en pacientes de menos de 20 años oeste
que está en sus 25 años aproximadamente
una erupción de toda la parte para la
tina y no se ve nada no era una cuestión
de estética pareciera que paranormal y
vemos en la parte izquierda toda esa
parte amarilla hagan de cuenta que
ustedes pasaron con una cuchilla y le
quitaron el 100% la primera capa del
diente y está toda la dentina expuesto
esa paciente hace
de estrellas
el que ha tenido sensibilidad es de eso
multiplicado de premolar a premolar
entonces diseñamos unas pequeñas
carillas y si las colocamos fantástico
seductor es genial
si alguien le hubiera dicho a él que
causaba eso está la llamamos idiopática
para descrestar al punto al paciente
idiopática no tenemos ni idea qué te
pasó allí eso lo vemos en estos casos
esta es una niña que me tocó ver
deteriorarse por bulimia cuando todos
los jugos gástricos suben a la boca eso
es como echarle agua razo un piso se lo
va comiendo lenta lenta lentamente y
después de que pasó el colegio llegó a
la universidad y logró controlar esto y
la tuvimos que rehabilitar de canino de
colmillo a colmillo todos los dientes
con coronas
decimos que mal estamos porque si
logramos cogió en este momento cuando
empiezan a aparecer esas manchas
amarillas con ese marco blanco y tenemos
productos en el mercado para untar no
para ir a un todo untar y reintegrarle
minerales a ese diente para volver a
remineralizar para que no pierdan los
minerales que hacen que ese diente se
empiece a desmoronar
y vemos que las caras oclusales se
perdían las ganas buenas son las tapas y
fantástico doctor no me hace table tops
la forma en inglés para que seamos más
fans y es más emocionante esta es una
corona y este es un table top y lo
restauramos realmente pero no lo
deberíamos estar restaurando lo vimos
saber prevenir para que no sucediera o
estos cuando llegan pacientes
rehabilitados con implantes y este la
situación quien se ríe con eso no hay
diferencia entre el diente de la
izquierda y la derecha no sé qué son
esos y terminamos así a productores que
era el provisional no nos dejan hacer
eso nunca desde que hacemos el encerado
que la forma como empezamos a planear y
a ver cómo va a quedar eso tenemos que
tener una proyección de cómo va a quedar
y este es el provisional
entonces si era porque creían que era el
provisional no iuean si con el
provisional no es muy similar a lo que
hicieron con el definitivo es muy
importante es nuestra primera forma de
mostrarles de que somos capaces y si
tenemos los conocimientos adecuados para
poder brindarle esa solución
entonces hay herramientas claro que si
se llama el cepillo de dientes todo eso
que me riega toda la vida también te
servía éste lo siento en el mío
si papá daniel beni para acá abrir la
boca
ya voy para para cepillar lo sigan
haciendo salido también sarita cierto
se han demorado mucho las compañías en
desarrollar una figura muy delgada lo
que ven arriba es una fibra y permea
delgada porque las fibras que tenemos
abajo estas son las bonitas la mayoría
pónganse gafas y lupas cuando van a
comprar el cepillo de dientes porque van
a encontrar unas fibras que parecen un
chut y estamos acostumbrado a que la
cepilla se sienta como a echarse
estropajo o piedra pómez no eso tan
blandito no me limpia si yo no siento
que saben mamés rastrilla pero créanme
mi jubilación es esta red tetra segura
yo cada vez voy a tener más trabajo
cuando ustedes compren las cremas con
blanqueamiento quienes polizza el carro
todos los días nadie no te ocurre no
seas
va a acabar con la pintura pero el
diente si me he hecho blanqueamiento
ventilado claro van a acabar con el
esmalte con la encía con todo entonces
si no usamos cepillos suaves que tengan
la capacidad de entrar en ese surco ese
circuito hagan de cuenta que este se
tiene que entrar en ese circuito y
limpiar esa parte me arregle
entonces tiene que limpiar todos esos
objetos tiene que limpiar allá en esa
cuevita entre el diente y la encía se
acumulan miles de bacterias y es el
principio de la formación de cálculos
cómo se forma un cálculo un cálculo se
empieza a formar desde el segundo en que
paramos de comer entonces como es esta
lucha como nos tenemos que cepillar que
nos decía eso para los lados ya no se
puede claro con los cepillos que les
estamos mandando era como un serrucho
las cosas que vemos en las erupciones
cervicales y la sensibilidad que
producimos son horribles esto sí es para
cepillarse así porque si no los cepillan
en este sentido las fibras no tienen
como entrar allí pero si no usan esos
cepillos pues no vale la pena entonces
busquen esos cepillos pónganse las lupas
miren que todas las cerdas sean a un
mismo nivel las cerdas redondeadas
llegan de ahí es como la muchacha que
limpia por encimita no mía levanta el
tapete y limpia por debajo esos son
estas limpian por todas partes entonces
estas redondeadas eran muy buenas y es
que es muy blandito si lo que pasa es
que te toca cambiar y tenemos que
cambiar ese paradigma tengo que comer y
cepillarme lo más pronto posible porque
sí
un cepillo muy duro va a tener la
capacidad de quitar esa comida que está
pegada en el diente pero se va a llevar
un poquitico de diente y se va a llevar
un poquitico de encía y yo feliz voy a
tener más pacientes pero no se trata de
eso de que es esta guerra es una guerra
de remineralización y de mineralización
vamos a ver quien gana para que pueda
entrar la caries se tiene que
desmineralizada el diente le tiene que
robar
partes a ese esmalte para que pueda
entrar y esto es acción de los ácidos
desde el momento en que empezamos a
comer lo que sea
en ese momento nos empieza a robar
minerales o no está en un periodo hace
que nuestros dientes tiene la capacidad
lucha pero después de unos pocos minutos
nueve minutos aproximadamente nuestra
salida dice uy cambiamos el ph estoy muy
ácido necesito volverme más alcalino
para que no se me termine la hice el
diente y resulta que no me hace pillado
los diente porque como maquillar aquí me
pierdo la charla entonces no me cepillo
los dientes rápidamente y esa saliva que
viene alcalina con la idea de
remineralizar los dientes me va a
realizar el mugre que tengo allí la
comida
el cálculo si yo logro romper esa zona
de remediación y le limpio el diente mi
saliva si me va a remitir a realizar el
diente y no me mineraliza la comida y me
forma cálculo entonces tengo que
aprender y cambiar voy a tener que
aprender a llevar mi cepillito felipe lo
hiciste bien ahorita con el cepillo
hay que llevar el cepillo a costumbre
mandamos con un celular de este tamaño y
nos vamos que va de andar con un
cepillito de este tamaño chiquitico es
fácil y las mujeres ni se diga nada con
un neceser así de este tamaño le dicen
cartera hoy en día pero parece que la
dejarán de la casa ahí cabe el cepillo
de dientes de todos ustedes de todos acá
entonces realmente tenemos que aprender
cómo se pasa la seda dental tampoco nos
enseñaron es se pasa por cada espacio y
debajo de la encía o sea que en cada
espacio la pasamos dos veces porque no
es para sacar el tarugo de comida que
está ahí metido y para que la seda
funcione tiene que ser multifilamento la
próxima es que comprensión tal después
lleguen las y si tiene pelitos
fantásticos está limpio
y si es aplanada mejor porque pasa más
suavecito entonces 90 y revienta y con
la encía no se hace un serrucho y la
abajo pero hecha una vez y está para
adelante una visita para atrás y ahí se
limpian bien los dientes
doctor que crema dental compro esta
tarea se la voy a dejar y corten al
odontólogo tiene que tener tres cosas
tiene que tener agentes bactericida es
algo que me mate todas las bacterias que
tenemos allí o doctor google pregunten
cómo se llama ese bactericida hay
algunos que son prohibidos en europa
afortunadamente y lamentablemente
permitidos en colombia y en américa
entonces miren muy bien cuáles de sus
bactericidas son los que estamos
poniendo en la mucosa porque creen que
nos da una tablet y acá para ponerla de
abajo para poner a funcionar el corazón
si tengo un preinfarto porque la mucosa
se absorbe rapidito entonces ojo con lo
que usamos no abrasiva nada que sea más
abrasivo yo puedo tener una bomba o una
esponjita con la bovril voy a acabar lo
que sea la superficie que sea entonces
no necesito mucha abrasividad necesito
un buen cepillo
que tenga agentes que remineraliza y que
a su vez me aumenten la resistencia
hacia los dientes y eso va a hacer la
tarea doctor necesito que me diga que
agente bactericida tiene si eso no habrá
sido porque no quiero nada ahora si voy
a vivir muchos años y quiero tener
dientes no le voy a ayudar con la
pensión suya doctor qué pena y la
remineralización necesito que me ayude a
aportar porque lamentablemente como
decías ahora los alimentos están siendo
cada vez más ácidos para que preserven y
duren mucho más tiempo en nuestras
neveras y por último la postura bueno
han visto un peladito pero hay tono
todos usamos los celulares y son así
pero lo que me aterra es cuando están
así doblan en 90 grados esta a mí no me
da doblan en 90 grados los ven así es
impresionante y la postura que está
generando tenemos sin querer un avance
mandibular y ese avance mandibular nos
genera todo tipo de problemas
articulares cefalea doctor en la niña
tiene un dolor de cabeza nos ponga la
placa minero que unas placas y usted es
el genio para eso que hace la niña
de 24 horas a 25 el celular y las otras
esta costa con un tour hugo si en la
cama tanto de ver televisión comprende
una almohada triangular grande una cosa
donde que uno come necesitas reclinó
matica sacos y que la cabeza que no
queden así o las señoras con las
carteras con nosotros mismos con los
computadores como los niñitos coloquen
los dos esa atención que tenemos que
decir cargando como si hubiera echado la
casa todos los días nos cambia la
postura totalmente nuestra cabeza y bota
en toda toda la columna y ese cambio de
posición nos está generando el bruxismo
el refinamiento de los dientes el clinch
y todas esas cosas entonces aprendamos a
tener una postura mejor
solo quería decirles que hacemos cosas
maravillosas
cuando busquen a un odontólogo busquen a
alguien que comprenda qué es lo que
están buscando que realmente cuando les
obres cargo usted de pronto bulgaria se
eso si fuera tu hija o tu hijo
contame todo lo que hay bueno y malo
contame cuánto tiempo va a durar lo que
me hiciste
y si definitivamente fue un accidente o
algo
está bien tenemos todas las herramientas
pero no nos dejemos decir en el caso del
que perdimos un diente citó yo te regalo
los dos porque para que quede más bonito
no hace me un hito solito te va a costar
más para nosotros es más complicado pero
tenemos todas las herramientas para
hacerlo por favor cuiden sus dientes
gracias
[Aplausos]